un voyage pour changer d'image dans ce
dispensaire de ouagadougou
carla bruni sarkozy est venu essayer de
démontrer qu'elle n'était pas seulement
un top model ou une chanteuse pas
seulement la première dame mais aussi
une femme engagée
je suis sur un autre terrain humanitaire
ou un terrain social et et mon mari et
même le gouvernement ne peuvent pas tout
faire et des choses que moi je peux
faire et je compte bien les faire le
burkina faso un pays sinistré par le
sida vingtaine de personnes traitées
mais probablement cinq fois plus
infectés
la première dame de france est venu ici
d'abord écouter à déplacement aux
allures ce stage d'observation
je ne prends pas du tout à la légère mon
engagement je citerai 10,80 une
débutante mais déjà une formidable
vitrine médiatique pour le fonds mondial
de lutte contre le sida
émincer le président du burkina la route
soit elle réfute tout rôle polluent et
le sujet ces femmes qui pensent que
quand on épouse un violoniste qu'on peut
jouer dans un orchestre voilà bien
consciente qu'il ne suffira pas d'un
voyage de 24 heures au burkina faso pour
imposer son rôle dans l'humanitaire
carla bruni sarkozy prépare déjà un
nouveau voyage en afrique et annonce la
création d'une fondation pour lutter
contre l'illettrisme
mais cette fois en france